Hi guys, I'm Erik Vosse and Dr. Strange is finally in theaters, and this movie's so great
I could talk about it for hours, and I will do that in another video, but for right now
I want to talk about the two
post-credit scenes after the movie; one in the middle of the credits with Thor and another at the end of the credits with Mordo
and I'm gonna break down what happens and what it means for the future of the MCU, movies like Thor: Ragnarok and
Avengers: Infinity War and hopefully a Doctor Strange sequel. Also the spoiler alert  - go watch the movie,
then come back here so we can gossip about it.
Okay, let's start with this first scene, the mid-credits scene
So we see that Strange is sitting down with someone in the Sanctum Santorum that person is revealed as
Thor and Thor is very adamant that he doesn't drink tea and instead he picks up this awesome self
refilling pint of beer which is perfect for Thor because now he doesn't have to smash it on the ground when he's done.
This Drink... I like it. Oh, I know that's great right?
Another!
So strange tells Thor that he's keeping a watch list of individuals and beings from other realms and Thor's adoptive brother
Loki is definitely on it. Strange then asks Thor what they're even doing in New York and Thor responds that despite some
Family drama, that sort of thing they're now looking for their father, Odin. Strange then promises Thor that he'll help them find Odin
so long as Thor vows to leave Earth with Loki and Odin right away - Which Thor says
Oh, yes; promptly and the Strange says great, allow me to help you. Now the biggest takeaway here
Is that Doctor Strange will definitely appear in Thor: Ragnarok
next year, which is already hinted at with that leaked set photo of Chris Hemsworth holding a piece of paper with
Dr. Strange's home address on it
In fact I'm thinking some version of the scene might end up being in Thor: Ragnarok, the same way that the post-credits
scene for Ant-Man ended up being a bigger part of a scene from Captain America: Civil War. So it looks like an addition to Hulk
appearing in Thor: Ragnarok
We're gonna get Doctor Strange in it too and I love that the three
arguably most powerful heroes in the MCU are going to be in a movie together. Hulk's gonna like, smash so many inverted buildings! Hulk
confused by
trippy
visuals!
Before we move on just a couple more interesting things about the scene. One is that Strange already seems pretty familiar with not just Thor
But his family members
And that's a lot more than other people on earth know about Thor's so already we're seeing strange having done his homework
But also why is strange so desperate and relieved to get all the asgardians Loki odin in thor off of this planet?
This is actually a big part of who Dr.. Strange's in the comics
He considers himself a protector of [Earth] from cosmic threats from other world
That's actually the main mission of the defenders in the comics historically his character hasn't really been on the best terms of the asgard
[so] it makes sense that he would be like yo demigod take your kinda get okay moving on to the second of these scenes the
Post-credits scene here. We see [Sheba] tell Ezra Ford's character Karl mordo and in the movie
He learns the secret that the ancient one drew her power from the [dark] [dimension]
Which is the same thing that the mystics are sworn to fight so mordo defects from the ancient one and in this [post-credit] scene?
We see his next dark move he tracks down Benjamin [Brat's] character Jonathan pangborn. We saw pangborn earlier in the movie
He was a paraplegic man who convinced even strange to go seeking out the ancient ones healing power?
pangborn had also learned the mystic arts from the ancient one
But he only uses his magic to move his body on a daily basis so that he can still walk
But here mordo confronts him saying I've been away for [many] months now
And I've had a revelation the purpose of a sorcerer is to twist reality out of shape stealing power
perverting nature like you and then morto attacks pangborn
Draining him of his mystic powers leaving him paraplegic once more I paint bornus
Why are you doing this and [mortal] responds because I see now
What's wrong with the world?
Too many sorcerers now this sets up more [toad] to be more the villain role
He [plays] in the comics Baron Mordo who repeatedly tries to destroy [doctor] [strange] at the ancient one?
but here
We did a new interesting reasoning behind his actions mordo learned the hypocrisy of the ancient one and now that shattered illusion
Led him to believe that he has to thin the herd of people practicing those mystic arts from the dark Dimension [by]
drinking their Magic milkshakes
And assuming that mordo is absorbing that mystic power and adding it to his own this sets him up as an emerging physical threat
[too] strange as well like you can imagine a scenario where [mordo] starts
Targeting mystics and absorbing their powers kind of like sylar [and] heroes making him a super dangerous enemy to overcome
But since right now we don't exactly know whether or not a doctor strange sequel even happen
We might see more to show up in one of the other movies the MCU has planned like
Avengers Infinity war which will supposedly tie in a ton of the MCU heroes into two movies
So maybe more dough will end up [siding]
Thanos like it could be one of those the enemy of my enemy is my friend
Situations or this could just be an open-ended tease in case Marvel wants to do more with this character which they absolutely should because xiulet
Lh2 [4] is an amazing actor and the McU would really benefit from having someone like him play this
interesting complex villain or you know the MCU could just keep having those one-off villains who don't really pose a threat and die at the
End of the movie and while we're talking about sequel ideas director Scott Derrickson said in an interview that he would love to bring
Nightmare into this universe now nightmare appeared in the first doctor strange comic. He's the ruler of the dream dimension
[that's] the realm that human minds go to when they sleep nightmare twists those dreams into nightmares
So he can feed off [of] the collective fear of all of us while we sleep now obviously
Derrickson didn't want to go this deep this quickly into other dimensions in this first movie
But it would be awesome to see the MCU expand this world in the sequel also
I just want to mention that nightmare rides this awesome. Demonic horse named dream stalker. That is such a cool name and makes Mr.
Ed sound like a real dick, [okay]?
let me know what you think in the comments and keep an eye out for another video on doctor strange that we got in the
Works also be sure to check out all the other videos that we've done in the marvel properties like guardians of the Galaxy Logan
Deadpool we cover all this stuff if you liked this video hit [like] and [subscribe] to new Rockstars and share this video around you can
Also support us on Patreon. Thanks so much to all of our current patrons you are awesome, and we love all you guys
Thank you so much for your support
You can hit me up on Twitter at Ea [vas] with any questions
or theories that you have you can also follow new Rock stars on Twitter at new
Rockstars for updates on our next videos alright guys. Thanks for watching bye